poésie féerie imaginaire voilà en
quelques mots
l'univers magique des marionnettes
proposé par la grange de la tramblais
jusqu'au 7 avril à l'initiative de la
ville de bois d'arcy
le 4e festival de marionnettes est
l'occasion pour petits et grands de
découvrir des techniques de manipulation
original une programmation qui se veut
diversifiée parce que l'art de la
marionnette déjà c'est un art qui n'est
pas spécifique à un style de
marionnettes dans le monde entier les
traditions différentes avec des
manipulations différentes soirées
théâtre le fameux guignol avec les
manettes again soon a été six fois
mettre sur table
sa marque se développe beaucoup parce
que voilà on voit même delà de la marina
discale objet concret l'imaginaire au
niveau 2 des gens du public et autant
pour le jeune public au théâtre et opéra
objets comédie musicale autant de genre
présentée au festival entre diversité
des techniques et diversité des cultures
les marionnettes invite au voyage les
gens pensent souvent les marionnettes
sont des marionnettes à fils ou
éventuellement à main alors qu'en fait
si la quantité technique et si en plus
de ça on fait un petit peu le tour du
monde
ce qu'on propose là c'est la diversité
qui devient tout à fait intéressante
diversité des techniques et diversité
aussi des cultures c'est le voyage
je suis satisfait à la fois véritable
spectacle vivant les marionnettes
transmettent toutes sortes d'émotions
qui font le bonheur du public
ça rappelle l'enfance à la fois c'est
pour les petits pour les grands parce
qu'on fait passer des messages
extraordinaire à travers les
marionnettes les deux prochains
spectacles à voir en famille auront lieu
samedi 6 et dimanche 7 avril